good evening everyone I'm Daniel
Stoneham I'm a junior here at Hillsdale
majoring in mathematics and philosophy
and I have the privilege of introducing
your speaker those of you who are here
at 4 o'clock probably already heard this
introduction but for those of you who
were not max Hastings is an author
journalist and broadcaster he was
educated at Charterhouse and University
College Oxford
mr. Hastings writes regularly for the
Daily Mail and reviews for The Sunday
Times and the New York Review of Books
he was editor then editor-in-chief of
The Daily Telegraph from 1986 to 1995
and of the Evening Standard from 1996 to
2002 he has received awards both for his
books and journalism the most recent
being the Chicago Pritzker military
library's literature Award for lifetime
achievement
he has written numerous books including
Inferno the world at war Armageddon the
battle for Germany Das Reich the march
of the ii ss-panzer division through
france and most recently catastrophe
1914 europe goes to war please join me
in welcoming sir max Hastings
well thank you so much for the
reintroduction Daniel and I really do
feel for all of you it's incredibly
sweet that you've all turned up here
today at all to hear
a selection of Brits talking about this
far away war but the fact that you come
back for second dose for hours off for
last one I think it's absolutely
enchanting so thank you all very much
for being here I'm going to talk tonight
largely about British generals although
many of the same strictures applied to
French and German and other commanders
no warrior tribe in history has received
as much mockery and contempt from
posterity as have been heaped upon
Britain's commanders of the First World
War
they are thought to have presided over
unparalleled carnage with a callousness
matched only by their incompetence they
are seen as high priests who dispatched
a generation to death their dreadful
achievement memorialized for eternity by
such poets as Siegfried Sassoon in one
of his most famous poems you wrote good
morning good morning the general said
when we met him last week on our way to
the line now the soldiers he smiled out
and most of them dead and we're cursing
his staff for incompetent swine he's a
cheerio card granted Harry to Jack as
they slogged up to Arras with rifle and
pack but he did for them both with his
plan of attack two generations later
General Sir John French
commander-in-chief of the wartime
British Expeditionary Force on the
western front together with his
successor Sir Douglas Haig will
caricatured by the British historian
Alan Clark in his influential although
wildly unscholarly 1961
the donkey's for which the author
belatedly admitted that he had invented
the quotation that he attributed to the
Kaiser describing British troops
as lions led by donkeys Clark's book
inspired the creation of the 1963
satirical musical oh what a lovely war
in 1989 the BBC produced the television
series Blackadder goes forth which I
suspect a good many of you even on this
side of the pond art will have seen and
which imprinted on a new generation of
viewers a vision of 1914 a teens
commanders personified by General Antony
and Cecil Hogg Burnie Melchett played by
Stephen Fry here was the mass murderer
as comic term or if you prefer the comic
town as mass murderer yet this was not
how most survivors of 1914-18
viewed their leaders in the walls
aftermath
despite gaping emotional wounds left by
the slaughters at Neuve Chapelle Luce
the Somme
Passchendaele and else well among
veterans returning from France there was
tremendous anger about the muddled
attending demobilization of Britain's
huge army which prompted strikes and
mutinous about the lack of a domestic
social moral or economic regeneration
that might offer some visible rewards to
justify the war sacrifice about the
absence of the quote home spit to heroes
that soldiers have been promised by
politicians while the war was being
fought but until the end of the 1920s
senior British officers such as hey
French plumber Bing rowlandson received
respect and even homage the belated
victors of the campaign
the Western Front were loaded with
British titles and honours painted by
Sir William open and Sergeant granted
places of honor at the unveiling of
countless memorials which the Cenotaph
in Whitehall was out in the foremost a
million people turned out for Haig's
1928 London funeral procession and
almost as many for the subsequent
ceremonies in n borough the public mood
in Europe and in Britain in particular
began to shift about the time the
depression began such accounts of the
war as Frederick Manning's the middle
plots of fortune in 1929 Edmund London's
under terms of war in 1930 siegfried
sassoon memoirs of a fox hunting mound
and memoirs an infantry officer
published in 1928 1930 Robert Graves is
goodbye to all that in 1929 and Erich
remarks All Quiet on the Western Front
depicted AB attracted agony in pursuit
of rival national purposes that
supposedly meant little to those who
perished in their names compounded by
the Brutalism of those who directed the
armies even if most veterans
unlike Maynard Keynes on some of the war
parents retained a belief that the
Allied cause have been wholly necessary
to fight people could see for themselves
the political chaos an economic
wretchedness prevailing across much of
the world at the end of the decade
following the Armistice the Great War it
seemed had not merely yielded
battlefield horrors of unprecedented
scale and intensity it had also failed
to secure any discernible benefit for
mankind or even for the victors in the
absence of evidence of Germanic evil
remotely matching the 1945 revelation of
the Holocaust
by the 1930s a diminishing number of
people in the Allied nations
acknowledged the kaisers Empire as a
malign an aggressive force the
frustration of whose purposes had been
critical some of the still believed for
Western civilization Britain became host
to a peace movement unrivaled in any
other country for its numbers and father
following the Oxford Union's February
1933 debate in which a motion was
carried by 270 by boats to 153 that
quote this house will in no
circumstances fight for its king and
country many people believed that a new
generation of British men had become
irredeemably committed to pacifism in
1934 Madame Tussauds Wax work calorie
responded to the change public mood by
removing from exhibition its galaxy of
Allied generals who had been catalogued
as quote the men who won the war by the
mid-1930s
a growing minority of British people
feared that it would prove necessary
once more to fight Germany this time
under Hitler making mock of the post
1918 slogan never again for a season
however the peace movement and its
collateral branch the appeasers still
held sway abomination of the Western
fronts generals had not reached the peak
that it would achieve 30 years later and
has since retained but there was
assuredly revulsion towards the blood
baths which the quotes brass house had
directed a British officer named Captain
basil little Hart who had served briefly
without attracting much notice on the
Western Front but since transformed
himself into a
pundit on military affairs who was
immensely respected on both sides of the
Atlantic and especially in Germany in
this role he did a lot to advance the
legend of British command India see
initially through a big study he
published in 1930 called the real war
little Hart was prejudiced if not
embittered by the unwillingness the
british army his senior officers to
treat himself as seriously as he
believed that his own gifts as a
strategic thinker
deserve he was a fluent writer who
produced a prodigious output of
journalism books and correspondence he
developed some good and even important
ideas about the future of war which like
most theoreticians he eventually
overstated foremost among them was the
claim that exploitation and maneuver and
technology most conspicuously the tank
could have played a game-changing role
earlier in the First World War and would
certainly do so in future conflicts
without the necessity for murderous
headlong collisions little hearts
denunciations of 1914-18 commanders
myopia and his assertions of their
culpability one favor with some very
important people are including Lloyd
George a former British Prime Minister
Winston Churchill and the novelist CS
Forester whom I some of you may have
heard of because he was the author of
some very well-known books about a
British naval here of the 19th century
called home blood which some of you may
have seen on television see as Forrester
was outstanding novelist who was then
emerging in the 1930s as one of the most
popular writers of his generation and in
1936 he wrote a novel entitled the
general that I will recommend to anybody
today as a wonderfully accessible
introduction to what went wrong
with the generalship of the First World
War and to the sort of people who
commanded the British armies in those
days Brittany basil little hearts vision
of the folly a lack of imagination of
that generation soldiers pervade CS
foresters tale about an officer who
rises to high rank amid the carnage of
Flanders the author back in 1936 set
himself to try to understand and to
explain what kind of man could have done
as did the commanders of 1914-18 to
launch repeated doomed frontal assaults
that kill their own troops of ten in
tens of thousands some before they reach
the British front line nevermind the
German one before I took my own wife on
a first visit to the battlefields the
Western Front I recommended the general
as background reading ahead of any work
of history and she divided eagerly in an
early chapter the author describes his
hero or antihero if you like who he gave
the name of Herbert cousin this
prematurely middle-aged bachelor with a
Distinguished Service Order one in the
burr war as he was on the eve of the
first world war in 1914 cousins mindset
very similar to that of his real-life
counterparts the generals who commanded
in that war it's a picture which in CS
foresters words quote seem savage
closely on the conventional caricature
of the army major peppery red-faced
liable under provocation to gobble like
a turkey [ __ ] hidebound in his ideas and
conventional in his way of thought and
it's no more exact than any other
caricature it ignores all the good
qualities which were present at the same
time he was the soul of Honor he could
be guilty of no meanness 'as even
boggling at those which convention
permits he would give his life with the
ideals he stood for
and would be happy if the opportunity
presents itself his patriotism was a
real and living force even if its
symbols were childish his courage was
unflinching the necessity of assuming
responsibility troubled him no more than
the necessity of breathing the man with
a claim on his friendship could make any
demand upon his generosity and while the
breath was in his body he would not
falter in the face of difficulties
although part of CS Forrester disdained
his hero or antihero and the role that
his kind played in the greatest human
tragedy ever then - before Britten the
author's sense of justice caused him
also to recognize his imagined generals
virtues cousin commanded respect
and indeed affection from his staff and
subordinates was a tireless worker and
dedicated professional of the highest
courage both moral and physical as a
corps commander he displayed enough
intelligence to recruit to his star
civilian experts in chemistry railway
scheduling logistics and suchlike
and to make full use of their skills
such as he knew himself to lack
Forrester ended his portrait of his
fictional character so much for an
analysis of Kosmas character at the time
when he was to become one of the
instruments of destiny yet there's
something sinister in the coincidence
that when destiny had so much to do she
should find tools of such high-quality
ready to hand it might have been that
would be a bold man who said so more
advantageous for England if the British
Army had not been quite so full of men
of high rank who was so ready for
responsibilities so unflinchingly
devoted their duty
so unmoved in the face of difficulties
of such unfaltering courage this has
seemed to me since I first read
foresters line
at the age of 14 one of the most vivid
character sketches that he ever made
among much else up it showed his
recognition that to brown the commanders
of 1914-18 as cowards who chose to lead
from the back one of the charges made by
some of the war poets was quite unjust
fifty-eight British general officers
perished in the conflict moreover it's
no more sensible to view those men as
clones of each other than to delineate
any other group of professionals and
contemporaries in such a way but there
was indeed a British military caste
which had its German Russian and French
and American equivalents and cousin
seems a fair exemplar among the more
foolish of popular proverbs is that
which claims cometh the hour cometh the
man occasionally in the course of
history great challenges have brought
forth great leaders Pitt in Britain in
the 1790s Lincoln in the United States
in the 1860s Roosevelt in the 1930s
Churchill in 1940 obvious examples more
often however societies have been
obliged to respond to threats to their
security and even existence under the
direction of unimpressive statesman and
bungling soldiers in the Napoleonic Wars
with the possible exception of General
Sir John Moore who perished at Corona in
1808
it was only with Wellington's
appointment as Peninsula
commander-in-chief in 1809 after almost
two decades of intermittent European
warfare the Britain identified a
commander of the highest gifts to lead
its forces on the continent few
societies put their best brains in their
armies and clever people are usually
better employed elsewhere
such a distribution of national talent
becomes a handicap only when great walls
break out in 1914 a century had elapsed
since Britain's last 1cs Forester
betrayed a calamity which dwarfed its
military actors by its enormity and
intractability
although the normals claimed to mine a
classic stature seems hard to dispute in
one important respect it's flawed it was
informed by a belief derived from little
Hart and his school of military thinkers
prominently including another British
military guru JFC fuller the better
allied generalship could have secured
victory a much lesser cost this view
suffuses the pages of the general an
assumption that General Sir Herbert
Kherson like his real-life counterparts
lack the imagination to adopt methods
that could have overcome the
difficulties of confronting the German
army and France and Flanders in a
seminal passage of the book Forrester
describes how after the failure of the
British offensive at Luce in October
1915 with enormous casualties the
commanders of the British Expeditionary
Force discussed preparations for new
offensive with more men more gas more
shells more guns the author wrote in
some ways it was like the debate of a
group of savages as to how to extract a
screw or piece of wood accustomed only
to nails they had made one effort to
pull out the screw by main force and now
that it had failed
they were devising methods of applying
more force still of obtaining more
efficient pincers of using levers and
fulcrums so that more men could bring
their strength to bear they could hardly
be blamed for not guessing that by
rotating the screw it would come out
after the exertion of far less effort it
would be a notion so different
anything they had ever encountered that
they would laugh at the man who
suggested it here
the novelist displayed the mindset that
caused Winston Churchill to write of the
same period battles are won by slaughter
and maneuver the greater the general the
more he contributes in manoeuvre the
less he demands in slaughter such Muse
remained widely held among the British
and American people's to this day in
we're both Churchill's dictum and
foresters analogy seem fundamentally
mistaken in the view of the best modern
scholars the First World War was in
their failure to acknowledge that at
that time no military means existed to
make possible a ready rotation of the
screw to open any cheap and ready path
to victory to pose such questions as are
asked by some modern critics of Great
War generalship couldn't they have
invented tanks sooner this is
meaningless as asking might the sleepin
plan of worked if the Germans had Panzer
divisions Western France dominant
reality was that the available means of
defense proved more effectual than the
means of attack even when a terrible
cost one side all the others assaults
achieved an initial breakthrough the
necessary mobility was lacking together
with appropriate command and control
technologies when Wallace's were
cumbersome and primitive rapidly to
reinforce an exploit local success this
changed only in the summer of 1918 when
the German army was much weakened by
attrition and the British had developed
new tactics above all through the
sophisticated management of artillery
for which field marshals to Douglas Haig
much-maligned deserve significant credit
even in the Second World War
little hearts faith in a quote in direct
approach the possibility of achieving
victory by manoeuvre rather than
attrition
prove justified only we're defenders
suffered a moral collapse as did the
French in 1940 the Italians in 1941 the
Russians in the first months of Hitler's
Operation Barbarossa the British in
Malaya in 1942 whenever a defending army
displayed staunch nurse and professional
competence as did the German army in
almost all circumstances and the
Japanese in most of the 1944-45 island
battles little heart was shown to be
quite mistaken in supposing that
enlightened generals could readily cut
keys to victory between 1914 and 18
British and French and later American
commanders were imprisoned by strategic
realities foremost among which was that
if the Allied armies remain supine in
their trenches they thus acquiesced in
enemy occupation of a large swathe of
France and Belgium in which 7 million
people lived under brutal subjection
here in lay the answer to the oft asked
modern layman's question why did the
Allies keep attacking
moreover the Germans enjoyed another
considerable advantage they could
concede a few yards or even miles of
occupied territory whenever it seemed
tactically expedient to do so to
entrench on higher ground for instance
while it was politically unacceptable
for Allied formations voluntarily to
yield French or Belgian soil even if
doing so would save lives overall loom
the cruel truth that the only ready
means of escape from the horrors of the
Western Front was to concede victory to
the Kaiser but in 1914 18 generals
deserved sympathy for the Italy for the
military challenges they faced to
modernize they still seemed repugnant
for their indifference to the massacres
over which they presided a vivid insight
into their emotional processes or lack
of them
was provided by the 1952 publication of
fear muscles to Douglas Hague's diaries
for instance as commander-in-chief of
the British Expeditionary Force he wrote
on the 2nd of July 1916 very early in
the Battle of the Somme a day of ups and
downs I visited two casualty clearing
stations they were very pleased at my
busy the wounded win wonderful spirits
the adjutant general reported today that
the total casualties are estimated at
over 40,000 to date this cannot be
considered severe and view of the
numbers engaged in the length of front
attacked by nightfall situations much
more favorable than we started today
next morning hang added weather continue
all that could be desired Winston
Churchill who knew the senior officers
of the war intimately both as a cabinet
minister and for some months as himself
a battalion commander on the Western
Front penned a vivid portrait of the
wartime British commander in chief soon
after Hague's death in 1928 he presents
to me in those raid years the same
mental picture as a great surgeon before
the days of anesthetics versed in every
detail of such sciences was known to him
sure of himself steady a poised knife in
hand intent upon the operation entirely
removed in his professional capacity
from the agony of the patients the
anguish of relations all the doctrines
of rival schools the devices and quacks
all the firstfruits of new learning he
would operate without excitement or he
would depart without being affronted and
if the patient died he would not
reproach himself Haig was a Roman
schooled since childhood to regard for
his
in the face of difficulties and losses
as an indispensable virtue for every
right-thinking soldier a view shared by
the senior officers of Russia France
Germany Austria Italy what seems to a
21st century society to have been harsh
insensitivity was to those who led
armies throughout earlier ages an
essential element of manhood and even
more so a warrior hood some of
Napoleon's greatest victories were
purchased at appalling human cost but
even today few French people think the
less of him because of this the first
Duke of Wellington sometimes wept when
confronted by the butcher's bills for
his victories but he never hesitated the
sacrifice men to battlefield imperatives
consider several British squares at
Waterloo which finished the battle where
they had started but with every man dead
in his place almost one in four of
Wellington soldiers were killed or
wounded on the 18th of June 1815 about
the same proportion of those engaged to
spell on the 1st of July 1916 the first
day of the song great captains have
seldom flinched from accepting heavy
casualties when circumstances seemed to
demand this their fitness of command
their fitness for command would have
been questioned had they done so in the
First World War the vastness of the
struggle imposed an unprecedented scale
of loss but what choice was there before
the military leaders saved to stiffen
their backs and carry on unless they
chose to resign their posts or concede
defeat to the enemy the literary culture
which dominates 21st century perceptions
burdens the generals
with everyone being blamed for the
struggles horrors but on the Allied side
at least soldiers for little or no
responsibility for having unleashed
Europe's catastrophe
it's almost impossible to make such
officers of lead Britain's for
between 1914 and 18 appear sympathetic
human beings to our 21st century
audience and they have scammed claim to
rank among the great captains of history
even Ludendorff on the German side who
considered himself a military genius we
must recognize that in the end
Ludendorff lost but they were men of
their time and it is as such that they
should be judged all societies view
history through nationalistic prisms and
the British indulged this as much as any
another persistent myth that we cherish
is that the First World War was much
bloodier than the second many people
like to believe that in the 1939-45
conflict Britain and the United States
suffered about smaller losses because
the army had more gifted and humane
generals who declined to sacrifice their
men as they've been sacrificed on the
psalm and of Passchendaele by such
commanders as Sir Herbert cousin
foresters invention but Paul Fussell
very influential modern American writer
was profoundly mistaken when he wrote in
the Great War and modern memory that the
conflict was uniquely awful and the
sleigh quote outside history unquote fit
matter for only literary rather than
historical examination in reality all
wars inflict horrors on those who fight
them as well as upon bystanders who find
themselves in the path of armies and
fall victims to their excessive life and
death in Western Europe in the 14th
century error of the Hundred Years War
and many other struggles were dreadful
indeed as they were also during the 17th
century 30 Years War which killed a
higher proportion of Europe's population
than perished between 1939 and 45 any
soldier who experienced the American
Civil War would laugh at the notion that
the First World War
happened in France was qualitatively
worse it's a childish delusion to
suppose that 1914-18 fighting-men
experienced worse thing than their
forebears that no they did not
for centuries past soldiers had fought
battles in which they were often obliged
to stand and face each other's far
sometimes at ranges of 50 yards or less
hour upon hour the hardships they
suffered from hunger weather and disease
were quite as severe as those faced by
competence on the Western Front
survivors of for instance Napoleon's
1812 Russian campaign in which 400,000
of his men perished would have mocked
the notion that what men did to each
other a deep or on the chemin de dam
represented a qualitative would be worse
experience than their own what changed
in the First World War was simply the
cultured citizen soldiers disdaining the
stoicism displayed since time immemorial
by warriors most of them were anyway
illiterate chronicle the conflict into
which they were plunged with an
unprecedented lyricism
moreover the absence of significant
strategic movement on the Western Front
generated a sense of military futility
which afterwards extended understandably
but irrationally and especially among
later generations rather than among
contemporary participants to the merits
of the Allied cause neither the poetic
achievement nor the sense of futility
were repeated between 1939 and 45 this
is odd because the second of the 20th
century's great clashes was much more
costly for mankind far bloodier
attritional clashes were required to
accomplish the destruction of Nazism
than those on the Western Front in the
struggle to defeat the Kaiser
but 1941 two 45s principal killing
fields its arms and they're DARS
Lane least and the losses were borne by
the Russians who suffered 27 million
dead and inflicted more than 80% of the
German Army's total casualties
the Western Allies accepted only a small
fraction of the material and human price
with destroying Hitler for four years
between June 1940 and June 1944 most the
British and later American armies
marched and trained at home while a
handful of divisions fought in North
Africa later Italy in the Far East and
our Titanic contest in arms took place
on the Eastern Front only in Normandy
during June and July 1944 that the
Western Allies go head-to-head with the
Germans in battles during some of which
some units losses max those of nineteen
sixteen seventeen eighteen in the second
half of World War two assisted by
superiority of resources such as
Marshall wash and peel Marshall Haig had
never enjoyed together with the fact
that the global tide had shifted
decisively against the Axis Britain once
and victories under the leadership of
competent if not inspired generals who
were indeed cautious about casualties
the disgust of their American allies but
it's difficult to argue that the British
commanders of the early Warriors
displayed higher skills than those of
Sir John French so Douglas Haig or CS
foresters imaginary Herbert cousin it's
a matter of personal taste whether such
British generals as Percival at
Singapore and the South African klopper
at Tobruk who surrendered their commands
to the enemy in 1942 rather than conduct
the sort of sacrificial stands that
Churchill wanted and such men as Herbert
cousin would have been happy to lead
deserve the applause of posterity for
their humanity
or castigation for their ignominiously
feel failure the dominant reality of
world war two was an Allen Brooke and
Marshal Montgomery and Eisenhower was
spared the odium of presiding over blood
baths comparable with those of 1914-18
not by their own genius but because the
Russell's did most of the killing and
dying undertaken by British Tommy's and
French poli use a generation earlier
it's sometimes suggested that allied
generals in Hitler's war is cured the
sybaritic lifestyle of commanders in the
kaisers conflict who created the legend
of Chateau generalship champagne
swinging brass hats living it up in the
rear areas this view too is factually
hard to justify Admiral Lord Louis
Mountbatten Southeast Asia command
headquarters in Salaam was notoriously
self-indulgent peel Marshalls Harold
Alexander and he stopped in Italy were
thought to do themselves remarkably well
as did most of the US Army's commanders
when champagne was available most
British American and German generals
drank it is enthusiastically between
1939 and 45 as they did between 1914 and
18 soldiers living in headquarters
inevitably live far more comfortably
than infantryman once again modern
perceptions have been distorted by the
literary culture of 1914-18 which myth
which fostered a myth of the first world
wars exceptionality in this respect as
in many others secrets are soon wrote in
another of his most famous poems if I
were fierce and bald and short of breath
I'd live with scarlet majors at the base
and speed glum heroes up the line to
death you'd see me with my puppy
petulant pace guzzling and gulping in
the best hotel reading the roll of Honor
poor young chap I'd say I used to know
his father well yes we've lost heavily
in this last scrap and when the war is
done on you
down dead I torille safely home and die
in bed fed by such brilliant derision
the delusion persists that the First
World War was unique in its chasm
between innocent youth sacrificed in the
trenches and slothful cowards skulking
at the rear in reality in all wars since
1914 for each rifleman confronting the
enemy at least 10 and sometimes 20
officers and men have fulfilled support
functions every surviving veteran of
World War two is today absurdly dubbed a
hero yet only a small fraction performed
any role which put them at greater risk
of death than they faced in civilian
life throughout the 1939-45 comple
Winston Churchill deplored the high
proportion of the British Army which
never had a shot card it fell to the
Army's chief General Sir Alan Brooke
repeatedly to rehearse to the Prime
Minister the argument that modern
conflict demands a long administrative
tail for the teeth arms fighting
soldiers of the 1939-45 era like their
brethren who manned office desks and ate
hot lunches no more than did Sassoon his
scarlet paste majors Sir Douglas Haig
and his fellow generals were not wicked
men in the way that Germany's commanders
in the second world war were indeed
wicked because they colluded in the
barbarous deeds unrelated to military
imperatives the British generals and the
French of 1914-18 did the best they
could for their country they possessed
virtues and vices
bred into the military caste over many
centuries but in the unprecedented
circumstances of France and Flanders
these qualities were tested almost to
destruction it's understandable that
today the British people declined to
celebrate
victory in 1918 because it's human costs
is deemed to have been disproportionate
but it's irrational it seems to me that
meanwhile they aren't airing Lee recall
an applaud the 1944-45 trials of
Eisenhower and Montgomery the contrast
is explained if not justified in part
but the fact that it proved necessary to
fight and overcome German expansionism a
second time in the course of the 20th
century this caused many people to
conclude that the earlier struggle had
been a failure the achievement of
victory in 1918 annulled by subsequent
events in some measure this was true but
a balanced perspective which ought to be
attainable the century after the event
suggest that if the kaisers germany and
won the first world war
europe would have paid a heavy forfeit
it's much too simplistic to look back on
the 1939 conflict was our good war in
1914 18 is it's bad one the war plates
are so often misinterpreted by modern
readers that it's necessary to remind
ourselves that most of the poetry that
was written by soldiers between 1914 and
1918 was intensely fiercely patriotic CS
Forrester the noblest in the general
recognized that his fumbling fictional
half hero like his real-life
counterparts was as much a tragic figure
as the men whom he led often to their
deaths it's almost impossible to
persuade a 21st century generation to
love or admire those commanders and
there's no reason why it should but we
can at least strive to understand them
to break free from the mire of cliche in
which our view of the first world wars
for decades been trapped a modern reader
who wants to understand something about
the nature
of the men who directed the battles on
the western front will learn much more
from the pages of sheis poster than from
those of many modern pundits an obelisk
who have been marching doggedly through
the centenary of 1914 bearing knapsacks
still laden with myths and cliches
almost all of them false thank you all
very much indeed
Thank You Lord Maxx for that insightful
lecture directly following our question
answer time there will be a book signing
on the mezzanine just near the exit of
Lord Maxis book catastrophe 1914 Europe
goes to war floor is now open for
questions we got a couple in the middle
well if we're a match standing by me
because I'm so terribly deaf to repeat
the question if I can't hear it
stand up aside from what little hearts
reasonings was for his animosity towards
generals why did popular culture start
to turn against the English and the
French leadership especially decades
after the war finished and especially
since the veterans had mostly come out
in favor for their leadership
why the sudden turn like in the 60s and
the 50s I think in the late twenties
it's very easy to explain that of course
that was the period at which Europe was
already beginning first of all the
Depression started and you had the
economic collapse that began in 1929 and
also you had Europe starting to dissolve
into political chaos and people looked
around and they said what has always
been for we were told we were fighting
the war to end all wars and it hadn't
produced an outcome and it's gone on uhm
it is extraordinary how once cliches and
myths get a catch hold especially in
Britain I think to some degree in the
United States it's frightfully hard to
turn them around and um this belief that
you know we've all read the steam now
Burroughs books and we've seen bounder
brothers and all the rest of it and this
idea that somehow things were done
better in the Second World War has got a
very deep hold in our culture
so in your first lecture today you
mention some stories of the inadequate
tactics in early 1914 and then today or
in this lecture you mentioned some of
the constraints facing the commander's
so I was wondering I have a three-part
question first did the tactics evolve as
the war went on second how quickly did
they evolve and third what effect did
that have on the casualties seen well
the first question about tactics evolved
me one of the things we always have to
recognize what I try and do is the
historian which i think is terribly
important it's so easy to try and impose
you know my favorite historian a british
historian called professor Sir Michael
hard and Michael is my sort of hero
among historians and he's always said to
me in intervals over the last 40 or 50
years he said we must never forget there
was a time that events now in the past
was still in the future and in all wars
these wretched military commanders
almost always have to start out by
learning in the hard way that they've
got it all wrong and it's very hard to
think of a war in history in which
people haven't screwed up big time at
the beginning I'm in the US Army we know
when it first appeared in North Africa
in 1940 42 you know had its share of
disasters and so on for the same reason
they all had to learn and I'm not really
persuaded that the generals the only one
who was much worse than most in 1914 on
the learning curve was the British
General Sir John French who had an
intense dislike of the French people and
no faith in their commanders whom he
said he didn't think much of the class
from which these people came and um when
after the first few weeks when the
French army was suffering defeat General
Saddam French I sent for your muscles
don't French sent a a telegram to the
British government saying he thought the
French Rhapsody hopeful hopeless people
to have his allies and he proposed to
withdraw the British Army and the coast
and sort themselves out and decide
afterwards what they were going to do
well
was poltroon of a very high order and I
think that was special but when you look
at the tactical issues of course they
learnt a terrible cost what the new
realities of war were but so they did in
the American Civil War so they need in
the Second World War but the difference
is when you get new situations in every
walk of life it always imposes huge
costs and the politicians make mistakes
and corporate businesses make mistakes
but when you make mistakes on the
battlefield the price is paid in lives
and of course that happened on an
unprecedented scale when you suddenly
get these are something like 10 million
men marching against each other in 1914
the scale of the revelation of the
discovery of this new world is just is
just more dreadful than than you know
when you're in the American Civil War so
far larger episode what was the second
ball the question I've lost it certainly
part of my question was how how quickly
did they learn and then the third part
was well very slowly it took about four
years um it certainly took the British
Army about four years but um you have to
recognize the techn you know the
technology didn't exist and I do hear
people say why couldn't they invent
tanks sooner why couldn't they invent
the internet sooner you know that um
that um that you have to it's not that
I'm trying to make these people seem
sympathetic human beings I'm trying to
understand the difficulties that they
face and this problem that um that if
you launched an attack and even if the
attack went quite well you're moving at
the speed of horses and men and you know
you don't have armored personnel
carriers in those days and so on and you
don't have good tactical radio and you
don't have all these things and um I
feel I say nothing I can say is is I've
even intended to make these people sound
sympathetic but gosh I sympathize I do
not think there was any easy path out of
their difficulties
it took them by 1918 the British Army
had become a far more sophisticated
fighting force but and it what it did in
the last few months the war especially
was was
remarkable but by that stage they were
marching over such appalling mounds of
corpses that nobody had felt like
applauding the fact that Great Britain
and France had relatively more
representative and democratic
governments at that time during during
World War one in your opinion did that
translate into a military advantage
perhaps in the sense of military
commanders being more willing to speak
openly or or there being a more
democratic discussion of strategies as
opposed to the more autocratic system in
the Central Powers I think looking at I
draw a lot I liked often think about
20th century history of the whole and
although both British and American
societies and the two World War suffered
paid some price for the fact for being
democracies and having in some ways less
efficient less speeded decision-making
processes than are some of the
dictatorships by and large I think we
did much better by being democracies
certainly the evidence the Second World
War
shows absolutely conclusively that
Germany started out with an amazingly
effective army but in the end the
achievement of democracies and the way
that the Democratic management of the
war effort was absolutely extraordinary
I think that was true
in the First World War - what's
surprising in a way is dictatorships I
think you could make an exception you
would say Starlin around a pretty good
war effort but a terrible cost in that
arm I mean another statistic which is
always quite sobering the British Army
and the Second World War lost about
300,000 people to enemy action a bit
more than that but there about American
army about the same while Stalin
according the most recent statistics the
Russians shot are about that number of
their own men for alleged Cardus or
desertion and second world war so in
other words yes Stalin round a fairy
active war effort but I'm amid such
torrents of blood that I don't think
anyone any of us would recommend this is
a model for how you run a war effort I'm
going back to your question about the
First World War but I would still say on
the whole the democracy did it better
where we got to gone you tell 95 yeah
early on you mentioned Robert Graves a
goodbye to all that yeah could you give
us a brief summary of his book and why
do you why you felt he was in error I
suppose when he made a great impression
actually Robert Graves was at the same
school that I was and he disliked it
almost as much as I did and he wrote in
he was um he wrote in a goodbye to all
that it was a memoir of his school days
and then of his experiences and he hated
the British Regular Army and he wrote
with intense bitterness about it and his
book had an enormous it was brilliant
book it's one the great autobiographies
of all time but he was as many of those
writers were he was unfair about he
presented this idea first of all of the
absolute imbecility of of the army and
its commanders and secondly of this idea
that what was happening in France was
that this was the worst the worst war
that mankind could ever have seen but
his book if you write brilliantly enough
you do sell the tale and and all of them
are graves Sassoon London these were
some of the greatest chroniclers of war
in human history and boy did they have
an impact and I say having given my
shared dislike with Robert graves of our
old school I remember reading goodbye to
all that for the first time when I was
about oh I don't know 13 or 14 and
thinking right on but actually nowadays
one does see that his picture of the
British Army in France it was I don't
know a lot of great impassioned writing
is unfair but it was pretty unfair
somewhere where's with microphone I'm
not even sure where the microphone
World War one was sold as a as the war
to end all wars and the treaty that at
Versailles
some people said was too harsh on
Germany and may have led to world war ii
all those i read a recent thing a new
criterion by Roger Kimball about maybe
the treaty was not harsh enough and that
perhaps the Second World War would have
been prevented if we had been much more
harsh on Germany he had suffered no real
economic losses of their industrial
capacity when you compared the treaty we
imposed on Germany after World War two
which really essentially eliminated them
as a threat what are your thoughts if
you want to read I mean the by far the
best recent book is by that brilliant
Canadian historian Margaret Macmillan
called peacemakers was a wonderful study
of Versailles and the key point if the
Versailles Treaty had ever been
implemented in full there maybe it would
have been a harsh treaty on Germany but
where you're absolutely correct in what
you just said most of it wasn't
implemented
the Germans ended up paying in
reparations less to the French than the
French have been forced to pay to them
after losing the 1870 franco-prussian
war and as you also touched upon the
Allies had the worst of both worlds in
1945 we occupied Germany and ran it
absolutely ruthlessly in 1918 the Allies
did not occupy Germany and they tried to
run it by remote control and that was an
absolute disaster and another good book
by a very good Harvard historian called
Allan twos he's an excellent book
arguing that from 1919 onwards the
United States was the only power with
both the financial clout and the moral
authority to have imposed order on
Europe if it had been willing to
exercise that authority which of course
it wasn't but I think one very important
point I'd make there is also belief that
we somehow got the peace in 1945 right
in a way that we did not
in 1919 well actually if you look at
what happened to the world in 1945 first
of all you had death nick cleansing on a
colossal scale in Eastern Europe as the
German minorities were thrown out which
killed somewhere between one and four
hundred thousand Germans you had 90
million our East Europeans falling into
Stalin's more to become part of his gas
did tyranny you had civil wars across
most of Europe you had um the lesson to
me is that making peace after huge
global wars is fantastically difficult
and rather as I think that the judgment
on the way that World War one has been
was run has been absurdly contrasted
with World War two in the same way I'd
argue that the peacemakers of 1919 and
Margaret Macmillan more authoritative
and makes this point they did not do as
quite as badly as a lot of people have
suggested and nor did everybody in 1945
do quite as brilliantly well if you'd
asked the huge number of people who died
in cast his circumstances in the
aftermath of World War two it was
absolutely horrendous in all directions
so it is just fantastically difficult to
do these things and while I'm terribly
against ever showing sympathy for
politicians I do think the one has to
recognize that it is an amazingly
difficult thing to do to get yourself
out of these huge global catastrophes
but it's a fascinating subject and a
very important one well up thank you all
very much I think you're absolutely
fantastic to put up me twice an evening
thank you song
thank you sir Mack